all right homeland security secretary
alejandra mayorkas
going to make his first trip to mexico
today to talk about mutual security
concerns
including the surge in migrants at the
border today's visit comes as border
agents in texas discovered a stash house
where smugglers were holding more than a
hundred migrants
the conditions described as inhumane
brandon judd is president of national
border patrol council how you doing
brandon good morning to you and
welcome back to our program here here's
mike pompeo
on on the policies that were that are no
longer
watch it's not the conditions down there
that have caused the current crisis at
the border it is the policies of the
biden administration
it's caused enormous devastation to the
human beings that are being trafficked
across the border
this is not only bad for them it's
really bad for the united states and
it's not a result of what's happening
in central america it's a result of
what's happening in washington d.c
i don't think you disagree with that
what does my orcas accomplish today
good morning there's not going to be
much that he's going to be able to do
when you're going to blame this current
crisis on conditions that exist in
el salvador honduras guatemala and
mexico that have always existed that
existed
during the trump administration yet
president trump was able to drop illegal
immigration to 45-year lows
when you're going to make excuses you're
not going to solve this this crisis and
there are easy solutions right now
there's just not the political will to
do it give me an easy solution in your
mind
hire judges hold people in custody
pending
asylum proceedings if we were to do that
we would be we would be using a legal
process
that is humane holding people in our
custody
pending their asylum hearing and then we
would be deporting people that don't
have a right to be here and we would be
giving relief
to those who have a legitimate claim to
asylum
that's the right way to do it but yet
this administration isn't doing well
there used to be remain in mexico and
apparently it worked overtime
finally there's these governors abbott
out of texas and ducia arizona
they're looking for more help now
governor abbott suggested last week
that texas would start finishing the
wall i don't know the status of that
right now perhaps you do but here is
part of their letter
uh securing our board with mexico is the
federal government's responsibility
but the buy administration has proven
unwilling or unable to do the job of
course
border states like texas and arizona are
ground zero for this crisis
and bear a disproportionate share of
these burdens additional manpower is
needed from any state
that can spare it it would be something
else if other states said
we can help you with that
well governor abbott has stepped to the
plate he's done more than any other
governor that i've seen in my entire
career
he's deployed texas resources to the
border so when we've been overwhelmed
when border patrol has been overwhelmed
he's stepped in and he's filled up he's
filled those gaps
but we've got to go back to june 10th
and what uh vice president harris said
when she said that she advocates for
undocumented aliens
that is the clear indicator that this
crisis is going to continue
she's advocating for lawlessness she's
supposed to be there
and she's supposed to be that beacon
that says we're going to have laws in
this country that we're going to enforce
to keep our citizens safe yet she's
saying she's advocating for lawlessness
well brandon judd thanks for coming by
today and her story continues and we'll
see how
the trip with majorcas in mexico works
out thank you sir
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now